en moins d'un mois on est passé de
quelques cas isolés à plus de 4500 dans
15 pays
la progression du nouveau coronavirus le
nco est fulgurante des 6,2 à l'émergence
et in china pourtant en soit le nouveau
coronavirus est loin d'être
exceptionnelle cette propagation par
exemple selon des données préliminaires
chaque personne infectée en contaminant
suite de deux à cinq autres c'est une
propagation importante mais semblable à
celle du strass en 2002 est beaucoup
plus basse que la rougeole par exemple
alors comment expliquer qu'il y ait
autant de nouveaux cas depuis 24 heures
je suis pas juif mais certainement je
pense qu'ils ont sous-estimé la
propagation des bus qui doivent être
pris avec plusieurs chaînes de
transmission qui qui qui existaient qui
existent encore on dit également du
virus qui le rend les gens si contagieux
qu'ils peuvent en infecter d'autres
nîmes lorsqu'il ne présentent aucun
symptôme de la maladie mais c'est loin
d'être prouvée jamais vu phénomène comme
ça avec les chorales un virus parce que
si rien n'est possible d'anciens si rien
n'est possible en infectiologie
mais en termes de probabilité je dirais
que c'est très de plus le nouveau core
un virus n'a pas démontré qu'il était
particulièrement dangereux
à ce jour son taux de mortalité de 2 à
3%
c'est plus élevé que celui de la grippe
mais beaucoup plus bas que celui de
strass en fait le problème c'est que le
nouveau coronavirus rend beaucoup de
gens très malades en moyenne une
personne infectée sur quatre et ça c'est
exceptionnel
nous gardons en tête que 25 % quand même
des croquis sont sérieuses en catégorie
sérieux donc c'est pas déjà qu'imam sait
déjà qu'ils sont qui doivent être
spotter spécialisé puis ça ça met
beaucoup de pression sur le système la
santé c'est pourquoi les chinois ont
décidé de construire des hôpitaux en un
temps record pour éviter que faute de
soins les cas graves ne se transforme un
grand nombre de décès mais chez nous ce
danger-là est pratiquement inexistant
is normal grondin radio canada montréal